ok ja die sache ist also ich hab mich
tierisch angst vor käfern und kanonen
und übelst großen wiesen und format ich
dachte gar nicht hier sein
wir reden heute über justin und justice
league das ist der große angriff der
warner studios zu denen auch der dc
comic verlag gehört auf die viel
erfolgreichere zumindest bislang
konkurrenz des marvel studios und die
bislang 31 filme sind unglaublich
erfolgreich gewesen und da hat dc und
damit eben auch der bonner konzern sich
gesagt na gut das müssten wir eigentlich
auch hinkriegen den superhelden an mehr
als genug und man muss sagen dass der
aufwand der damit betrieben wird
durchaus das potenzial hat an die
avengers heranzukommen
man muss aber leider auch sagen dass
alles das was disney gemacht wird an
zusammensammeln ebendieser superhelden
truppe an den verschiedenen kabbeleien
zwischen den einzelnen figuren an den
seltsamen gegenspielern eigentlich immer
nur an das erinnert an den rest links
gemacht worden ist
das glaube ich nicht
was bist du eine die cloud
darum sind wir jetzt in der seltsamen
situation angekommen dass die
superhelden film obwohl sie unglaublich
erfolgreich sind immer langweiliger
werden immer mehr die selben schema
wiederholen wenn diese hier kommt ein
etwas seltsamer superschurke namens
steppenwolf vor der nicht mehr ist als
ein abziehbild des bösen und
dementsprechend harmlos wirkt gerade
weil er besonders schrecklich sein soll
nied ii bewies und so bleibt dann
letztlich bei diesem film eigentlich
nicht viel mehr als ein paar wirklich
sehr witzige dialoge für die man
ausgerechnet joss whedon als
drehbuchschreiber gewonnen hat ja schon
die ganzen erfolge verantwortet hat
jetzt ist er zur konkurrenz gegangen und
gibt zumindest muss man sagen als
schreiber sein bestes wie viele von euch
gibt es nicht genug aber inszeniert hat
leider gottes zack snyder und zack
snyder hat zwar einige ganz fantastische
comicverfilmungen gemacht aber
mittlerweile kennt man die ewig
verlangsamten bewegungsabläufe die
dadurch besonders dynamisch wirken
sollen das in gewisser weise
hochgeschwindigkeit in zeitlupe gezeigt
wird und die kampf posen mit
unglaublichen sprüngen und
aufeinanderprallen von körpern aus dem
effeff und er wiederholt dieses
erfolgsrezept in justice league in zwei
stunden mit einem unendlich lang
vorkommen
wir brauchen keine neuen helden die
alten sind gut genug aber wir brauchen
einen völlig neuen umgang damit wir
brauchen neue chance im superhelden
genre und so gesehen ist leider gottes
justice league das originellste was in
den letzten jahren diesbezüglich auf den
markt gekommen ist sie sind einfach
abgehauen ja schon irgendwie unhöflich